[Music]
this road might not look like anything
as special but what if I showed you the
same road a few years earlier and notice
anything different here's a better angle
of that the old road has four lanes for
traffic the new one has two and now
there's this middle lane for left-hand
turns there's also a new bike lane this
is what transportation planners call a
road diet and it's a very popular way to
make the roads safer over the course of
the 20th century four-lane roads became
an American institution it all started
with the release of Ford's Model T in
1908 a few decades later there was one
car for every two households in the
states and by the 1960s many roads
became so busy the traffic engineers had
to figure out how to add capacity so
they added lanes a lot of payment was
getting put on the ground even where
maybe the population and the traffic
volumes weren't so high that really we
needed that pavement but we wanted that
page sometimes you know your eyes are
bigger than your stomach fast forward to
the present day and we're left with some
overbuilt roads that are pretty unsafe
and crash reduction is a major benefit
that planners can achieve with just a
bit of paint four-lane roads have quite
a few conflict points those are places
where accidents could happen these are
emerging accidents left turn lane
crashes and rear ends now look at what a
three lane reconfiguration does there
are far fewer crash points a road diet
can also make left-hand turns suck way
less the shared middle lane takes left
turn is out of the traffic flow so they
won't hold up drivers who want to
continue through and now left Turner's
will only have to cross one lane of
traffic instead of two which will
eliminate broadside acts
and the benefits don't end there by
slimming each lane in the road the road
diet can reduce travel speeds by around
seven miles an hour narrower lanes can
cause that psychological impact on the
driver to float a little bit the Federal
Highway Administration notes that
smaller lanes reduce striving speeds and
while a six mile an hour difference may
seem modest it can make an auto accident
much less deadly narrower lanes also
leave more space for expanded sidewalks
or bike lanes your pedestrians feel
safer it might give you more green space
to separate them from your vehicle and
your bicyclist might have a dedicated
space to ride in the midst of these
changes the amount of traffic lane is
gone from two to one so if you drive a
car you might assume that the trade-off
of a road diet would be congestion how
could traffic not increase that's
usually their concern before a road diet
is implemented as not what happens the
volume of the roadway is still sustained
we wouldn't want to put a four three
lane conversion on a piece of roadway
that would then push half your traffic
somewhere else and what we found in in a
couple of places is that it actually
makes moving through town easier but
traffic flow is only one part of the
equation you've got to also balance
commercial and safety benefits too
especially if this is through an urban
corridor where you've got businesses
you've got a coffee shop it works like
huge people moving it doesn't take
traffic away from that corridor and it
reduces those those rear ends that then
do stop the road so the state of Iowa is
conducting a new road survey because
it's worked really well for them a study
of fifteen streets in the state saw a
crash reduction rate of nearly 50% at
the same time the diet didn't
substantially disrupt other activities
along the quarters
a key factor was the traffic volume
measured by engineers as annual average
daily traffic most Road diets will run
into problems as you approach that
15,000 vehicle number in Iowa
many roads don't get that much traffic
the same could not be said for the
suburban context in California a study
comparing Road diets in Iowa to
corridors in California showed that
California streets averaged about double
the amount of daily traffic the same
kinds of Road diets resulted in a much
lower crash reduction rate in California
significantly lower than the reductions
in Iowa this is not to say that the road
diets in California are an outright
failure it's just a difference of
context for the road diet and the
success of a road diet is driven by so
many other factors economic impact
land-use or level of service to name a
few so the case for ou diets is pretty
clear they do slow down streets and they
do reduce crashes but whether or not
that's worth the trouble depends very
much on the context of the world that
surrounds the road
[Music]
you
[Music]